hi I'm Brian Elliot welcome to behind
the brand today we're here with
entrepreneur wine enthusiast businessman
extraordinary and author Gary Vaynerchuk
Gary welcome to the show thanks man it's
good to be here it's great to have you
man I appreciate that so today we're
talking a little bit about the Thank You
economy tell us about the book and why
you wrote it I wrote it because I think
there's a huge debate about the ROI of
social media I don't love that term
social media I just think it's clear to
everybody there's a change in the air so
I just want to talk about business
trends and something that I'm seeing as
the consummate salesman as the guy who
loves ROI
who wants to close the deal it blows my
mind that I'm transforming that the
businesses I'm involved with and
consulting for are looking to transform
and there's a very different way to do
business today ironically all these new
gadgets and apps and technologies are
bringing us back to old small town rules
and that's what I talk about in this
book I tried to focus on some case
studies you know start to kibosh some of
this that you know social media is just
like black magic or that it's a silver
bullet that's gonna save your business I
tried to write a practical book on a
subject matter that I think has a lot of
hype a lot of over hype and definitely
some under hype depending on which
sector of the world you're at so who's
your at it for you know I wrote it for
probably corporate America more so than
my prior book crush it you know crush it
was super entrepreneurial like go do
this there's an opportunity I became
wine famous internet famous because this
platform has emerged that's the internet
it's just a maturity the internet this
is a little bit more for you know you've
got a business you've got a logo whether
it's the Nike swoosh or it's your you
know lawnmower service that has five
clients put that logo into play humanize
it understand one-on-one marketing is
here use the tools that are 2011 based
not 2005 based and and there's some
upside and so you know a lot of brand
managers corporate America agencies I
definitely thought about this and this
is a very transparent answer I'm gonna
try to give you as much good stuff
because I like you and I want to give
you some juicy nuggets I brought this
book thinking like I want companies to
buy a thousand copies of this right so I
definitely wrote it you know crush it
was like hide this book people gonna
quit our business right this is very
much like oh crap this is where the
world's going our people need to
understand since by 45 copies for our
agency or hey let's buy 10,000 copies
for all our employees so you buy a
thousand copies for the company are you
hoping that it goes top-down or does it
matter just couldn't you can kind of go
out there yeah is the consummate
salesman I want to I want people to read
it you know
yes top down works bottom up works I
mean there's been a lot of people who
are inspired by this who forced the CEO
to read it and so goes bottom-up then
back down yeah
you know when you're trying to move
product you know as long as you
understand how you're doing it you're
not being cheesy about it I'll come from
the side upside-down flip over and no
shirt on whatever it takes whatever
angle I can get it to go into that's
fine by me I think it comes down to
having quality content and it's been
funny the book just reappeared in the
New York Times and Wall Street Journal
bestsellers list that has you know me
excited that feels like I'm running a
marathon with this book yeah it's got
legs a little bit yeah I'm excited about
that
that's excellent I wanted to know more
about you know the title is is excellent
you know a lot of people have talked
that customer service is the new
marketing talk to us about what the
Thank You economy means though like what
is that yes so the word economy is a
big-boy word right i sat with it for a
while I was like if I'm gonna use the
word economy I need to understand that
people gonna take potshots at this this
isn't thank you theory yeah this isn't
thank you moment did you have some
alternative titles not really I came up
with a title because I was being
interviewed about crush it post crush
it's selling really well and everybody
kept asking you the same thing like how
did this do so well you didn't to
traditional media you know you came out
of left field why is this doing so well
and finally said Thank You economy and
the host was like huh that's interesting
what's that and I'm like I'm not sure
but I like the way that just came out
yeah let me think about it and what it
meant was I paid forward so much to my
community I gave so much I replied to
tens of thousands of tweets I applied to
hundreds of thousands of emails I put
out a thousand wine shows for free every
day that by the time I came out with a
twenty five dollar product i guilted you
know my community into buying it yeah
they were already sold they were sold
yeah and it's because it's and they were
sold the same way you're sold on what
you would do for your parents or your
older brother or your children there was
context there I had built up equity
right they were my friends
yeah and so I believe that that is a
business pattern that is developing so
that's what I've really tried to figure
out why did that happen for me does that
work for corporate
that's why I started vaynermedia I
started listen client work is like
getting punched in the nose like I'm not
that interested in client work as an
entrepreneur you know I mean this is not
going to be my career vaynermedia is
going to be an interesting step along
the way and I did it because I wanted to
understand corporate you know I knew how
to be an entrepreneur I knew how to
build a small business you know 50 60
million dollar business that's a small
business right even though it's big for
a family it's small I wanted to
understand how billion multi-billion
dollar 100 billion these big marque cab
companies worked yeah I started
vaynermedia that's what gave me the ammo
to write this book because I know that
the brand manager at Trident or or an
agency or somebody works on the Puma
brand is gonna learn something from this
and I put those pieces together and
that's kind of why I did it so let's
back up just a little bit talk about
your background how you got from there
to here people who are watching this a
lot of the people are small business
owners entrepreneurs they look at you
you know with 800 thousand plus people
following you on Twitter and probably
you know millions of web views and Wine
Library TV but how did you get started
in all this how'd you get this job
you know I'm an immigrant I wasn't born
here my my dad and mom are my heroes my
mom raised me impeccably she didn't
still obnoxious self-esteem in me which
makes me super confident but I come from
zero place so I think I'm balancing that
ego versus the humble missus of being an
immigrant my dad taught me great things
including that yeah which is the biggest
thing that saved me because as a
storyteller you know as a marketer
there's that [ __ ] in me and my dad
was able to suck a lot of that out yeah
give me the right balance what is that
is that they're like my word is my bond
absolutely yes okay absolutely I mean
and listen I have so much chaos right
now I get hundreds if not thousands of
emails a day tons have been take and
there's things that will fall through
the crack I have an assistant I have
people around me so things will fall
through the crack but it's always how
you make good right yeah so like I fight
fiercely for having a good legacy well I
like that because I think that's how
most of small business is still done
these days
absolutely it's done by a relationship
it's done by you know handshakes and all
the business to they just don't talk
about it as much
right the mergers the acquisitions the
big boy stuff the big girl stuff that
happens with relationship - yeah you're
right you know I was flying down here
ironically with the gentleman who was
telling me about stuff he's
with the government guy was like 70 80
years old and telling me amazing stuff
and just you know it's it's he said it's
all about relationship I said you're
talking to the right kid yeah you know
he's trying to preach it I'm like boy am
I sold yeah I'm like I'm a 90 year old
man and a 35 year old body and he
started laughing we talked absolutely I
got here because my dad built the
American dream for me you know he built
a small family business a liquor store
business I was whisked into it when I
was 14 I have enormous entrepreneurial
chops I'm natural right I'm like an
athlete kind of sales was your family
doing at that time we were three to four
million dollar business behind I got
involved full-time just wine just wine
liquor and beer shoppers discount
liquors from 98 to 2005 and that's
seven-year window I grew it to a forty
five million dollar a year business
amazing um and so I was very good I'm
good at what I do
what people want to know how you did
that because that's I do that
traditionally Direct Mail radio print
you know that big advertising I paid
myself twenty seven thousand dollars a
year so I could hire good people I built
infrastructure and systems I collected
data I did everything you have to do
it's never one move it's not having a
Twitter profile or a Facebook fan page
it's not having a LinkedIn profile it's
everything it's everything you've got to
do everything I just left my biggest
brain that I've ever built Wine Library
TV to start daily grape because I wanted
the challenge of building a subscription
model and a mobile play I'm pointing to
my pocket you know I just think that um
I got here I got there I'm going to big
places because there's a couple things I
understand which is number one
if you don't evolve if you don't play
within the reality of the marketplace
you'll get run over that's a very strong
message throughout the whole book
absolutely on page 42 it's like one of
my favorite spots in the book but there
are too many businesses that are still
holding back watching the social media
train rush by convinced that if the
destination is so great another train
will come along soon enough they seem to
think that it will be going more slowly
and the ride will be safe and steady and
they'll be able to catch up with
everyone else who jumped on early
they're wrong though the next train will
come and it does show up it'll be going
fast and full speed to some other
equally exotic and unknown place yeah I
mean thanks for reading that I I think
that fast following is
interesting yeah and it's a skill set
and as a matter of fact I actually think
it's something I would be naturally good
at I've come to the realization last six
months that I'm probably not gonna start
the next Facebook or Twitter but it's
very obvious to me very quickly when
something's happening and I'm always
willing to go all-in and that's why I
win bigger because I don't hedge you're
an early adopter I'm an early adopter
and more importantly I'm an early
business adopter yeah I feel like a lot
of the people that were early into the
social media thing we're very zen
we're very journalistic we're very you
know I'm business I I know there's an
ROI to this because I practice things
very quickly and then I talk about them
you know it's funny I don't I don't
dream of the future I live in the future
and then just talk about it I'm never
scared the reason I always pound my
chest and why I'm so focused yeah
it's cuz I'm living it I've had the ROI
of social media happen already yeah I've
been living this everyday and breathing
it 24/7 365 for six years yeah you know
this isn't new to me you know people
think it's funny when I talk about
Twitter or new things on stage in 2011 I
was talking about this in oh seven yeah
where people like what you know so I act
very quickly I'm a doctor but I try to
turn into business very quickly yeah and
you're talking to absolutes right I get
apologetic if I'm not it's one of the
first things you say in the book I'm
just I just think I'm right you know I
know the how obnoxious that just came
off and people are as I just delivered
that people like you know I just think I
am I don't know what else to say and
more importantly it's because I've
already felt it I am NOT note Radames or
Yoda I'm not predicting I'm doing and
then I talk about it I just happen to be
doing it so early that it's so obvious
to me yeah
what does caring look like you talk a
lot about caring talk about nurturing
your customers taking good care of it
what does caring look like what is it
really that's part you know how you just
asked me that question yeah if the
answer popped to me so quickly and it
feels like so right to me
every customer knows every person who's
watching this right now knows exactly
what caring field looks like
I think the consumers [ __ ] radar is
much better than we've ever thought it's
because now they can communicate with us
and tell us you know a Super Bowl
commercial runs ten years ago and and a
couple people like from the agency are
sitting in their house and there are 10
friends who are watching it with them or
like that was so funny and everybody
and everybody thinks it's awesome now
you go to Twitter and everybody tells
you it sucked yeah there's a very
different world we live in today I think
could sumers know what's going on
caring looks like to me it's not
something I see it's something I feel
right and it's just very obvious to me
when somebody listen people do nice
things for you because they're trying to
get the brand equity out of you for
themselves I see it every day
and then I see if when it's purely their
intention for what's good for them and
then I see relationships where it's good
for both and then I see relationships
that are really Zen and they're just
true and trying to do it good for you I
actually prefer the one in the middle
I'm not comfortable with somebody just
doing what's good for me
right I'm not comfortable with that yeah
and I'm not comfortable with the person
that's just trying to suck out my brand
that's pretty rare anyway right I mean
which ones though the one that they're
just trying to do something for you is
you get some artistic people out there
that are going there yeah but I love the
middle and I love when people don't
[ __ ] the middle yes like yeah you
brought me out here in a snap but it's
good for you too and let's like let's
work together I love that I hate the
people and there's a lot of them the
leeches they want it all for themselves
and that's big businesses that's a small
one person entrepreneur yeah you know
it's what's in it for them I mean it's
very rare that I I do business with the
people that come at me like I want to do
this and they're not hiding that there's
some inherent value for them yeah they
don't have to make it at the four-four I
don't need somebody to come to me and
say hey there's gonna be awesome for me
to I don't really need you to do that I
think that's almost untold a month's
entrepreneurs and business people
because you get it because I get it yeah
and and and what I've gotten much better
at is I putting higher value on that for
me and brands need to do that businesses
need to do that the customers not right
don't be scared of social media cuz
somebody says yours place sucks you
gonna jump in their debate it I mean
it's all it's all a level playing field
now and so caring is something I think
every person here feels and and in the
book you talk about if this were you
know the early 20th century or earlier
this wouldn't be anything new but
because we're in this digital age and
it's becoming less personal this
carrying out people one on one to one is
kind of what where it's coming back
around to you right how expensive would
it be for you to run a commercial during
friends in the 1990s damn expensive yeah
millions everything's changing I mean
people are even watching commercials I
want the people watching this right now
to think if they have a DVR TiVo and
don't watch a single commercial all year
I mean those numbers are growing they're
staggering the world is changing this is
this is the biggest culture shift we've
ever lived through and it's not social
media it's the internet right the
consumer Internet the one that started
in 95 I don't want some nerd saying
actually Gary it's 19 I know I'm talking
about when people started using it yeah
when AOL spammed our actual mailboxes
that thing is a baby that is a 17 year
old product it's five minutes in in a
schema business yeah it's
revolutionising everything and the app
bats that every business now has cost
less it costs sweat equity it's tough to
scale the values in the humans but it's
a culture shift a big one and it's
leveling the opportunity for different
businesses to do different things and
the companies that understand it will
survive and win and the ones that don't
will lose plenty of businesses went out
of business when the television age came
yeah plenty of businesses went out of
business when the video game market came
and look at the soap opera industry
going out of business
why farmville women are playing games on
Facebook instead of watching one or days
of our lives and so I just think that
I'm stunned that people don't recognize
how obnoxiously big this all is I mean
and it's gonna be I mean I can't wait to
watch this in five years and be like see
because in five years from today the
world's gonna look totally different no
YouTube no Facebook no Twitter seven
years ago so Gary who's doing it well
what brands are doing a good job with
the Thank You economy or social media in
general this is tough right because this
is where I think I'm doing a really bad
job I know our clients are doing it well
and that's like the cheesy answer I'm
not spending a lot of time paying
attention to other people I think some
people may view that as a strong
weakness I view it as a strong strength
I just and there's probably the right
answer is probably a little bit in
between I'm probably doing a little less
paying attention to competitors and
other brands then I should be so this
question is tough I I hate that I'm
probably not answering it as well as I
could well that's a swim yeah well you
were a little bit critical of the Old
Spice it works because the Old Spice
campaign was a social media campaign
which doesn't exist they did this hoopla
a lot of people know what happened you
know they took the guy from the
commercials they masked a lot of people
got a lot of followers did YouTube
videos did one-on-one marketing they
don't listen if you really carefully I
give them a lot of credit up to
last point what I did right they did
almost everything right
they created context in the character
they made it one-on-one they linked
baited Kevin Rose and Alyssa Milano
they went into into reddit they did
almost everything right until the big
money shot which is that they left that
community sit there and they left them
yeah they left the community and so I
think that that was a huge mistake I
think that you know and what to people
that didn't see it they amassed tens of
thousands of Twitter followers and then
at replied one of them in the course of
six months because they just wanted to
mask them they looked at it as data
collection they looked at it as an email
newsletter yeah there's a little
collection versus connection thing
that's a very nice one I haven't heard
of that believe it or not that often
yeah that's exactly what happened it's
it's the one-night-stand versus marrying
somebody they one-night stand their
customers I think you need to marry your
customers because I think we're all
going to map and this isn't this is it
anybody watching this video this is the
moment you've been waiting for this is
the only thing you need to take away we
are going to map through UI and UX
through ad platforms through AV testing
we are going to map customer acquisition
awesome Holy Grail Facebook and and
Technology is gonna help us map why do
you think farm bill and Groupon and Gilt
Groupe do what they do we will map
customer acquisition the battlefield
going forward for all of us production
companies why guys business peeps is
going to be a retention lifetime value
and the only way you do that is by
giving a crap and being human the
businesses that understand how to get
there in a scalable way whether there
are good trillion dollars or nine
dollars are going to be the ones that
are relevant going forward I like that a
lot of the people are watching want to
know sort of want to break this down
probably and understand you know you say
that the Old Spice campaign was great in
many ways but they fell short they fell
short because they didn't respond or
engage their people they were just
collecting now I think on the Old Spice
campaign side the brand managers might
say we sold a ton of product we did
great our ROI was you know through the
roof better than expectation they were
on coupon during that time yeah so the
bait of you know of what really helped
move the product is there but they did
do well they got me to buy
a stick of Old Spice deodorant I did I
went to CVS I saw it I was like oh it
kind of all resonated you know she's
branding right impressions emotion I
bought it but then and not a lot of
people gonna do this and they're not
worried about my business because they
handle it so poorly now I don't buy it
and they've lost my business forever so
they did more damage than they did good
I think it's a very interesting debate
what I know is this they I don't believe
they created any lifetime value and I
don't understand how to go forward
without lifetime value so then what's
the what's the lesson here for small
business owners and entrepreneurs that
when you invite 80,000 people into your
universe and you got them there because
they're excited you don't just never
talk to them again and that's just
everybody understands that a new
restaurant that opens you don't run a
bunch of ads in town everybody gets
pumped you got a big-time chef everybody
shows up and there's no employees or
anybody talking to them they didn't
follow through they didn't follow
through you know if every woman out
there knows exactly what I'm talking
about
you had a great date it went awesome and
he didn't call yeah how does that feel
like crap that's how those customers
felt there was no engagement no
relationship and in a world now that we
live in which is based on word-of-mouth
were based on word-of-mouth because
that's what Facebook and Twitter are
bringing to the table it's bringing
word-of-mouth on steroids where context
is being created I like this pizzeria I
hate this burger
I like this airline I hate this hotel
these impressions are being thrown at us
from our friends and being indexed by
the way absolutely but more importantly
when your aunt says that this place is
delicious instead of an advertisement it
matters more because you have a
relationship with your aunt that
endorsement matters more and these
things are happening the way we do
business is changing it's gonna be a lot
less of talking and a whole lot more of
listening that's a culture shift from
the way we've done business for the last
150 years and there's a lot of pain and
changing into that game it's kind of
like businesses have been playing
basketball for the last 200 years and
all of a sudden we said you know what
it's now about hockey some people aren't
gonna translate Gary thanks so much for
being here thanks for having me lots of
fun yeah it was good Gary Vaynerchuk
author of the Thank You economy go out
and get it